thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a top
billing wild ride with Stevo we've got I
think the first leading man in major
Motion Pictures that we've ever had Big
Time movie star a-lister Josh DeMille
and man you wouldn't expect a guy at
that level to be so uh intimate so open
so honest so vulnerable I mean man it
really uh we really open up and and go
deep so strap on your seat belts baby
this one's intense let's get into it
well here we go man we'll Dive Right In
let's do it okay
ladies and gentlemen I'm not gonna
pretend to know how to say this guy's
name
well if you're in France I think it's
Duomo but we've always said demel
demelia because our mutual friend Sam
macaroni yeah he he always called you
Josh DeMille yeah and then I I gave him
a shout this morning to try to get some
inside tips yeah and he says that you're
gonna tell me it's do Hamel well it like
I said the the proper way is do a mail
that's what the that's what the french
say but
I don't know we just we just dropped the
ha somewhere in there
okay well then uh I was I was I would
have just said do Mel yeah and then I
asked if you're then you would have been
right Steve
our buddy Sam macaroni messed me up was
it is he French and he's like no he's
Dutch I'm like how does that make sense
oh he said I'm friend or he said I'm
Dutch yeah I don't think I have any
Dutch in me man and now I'm I'm off to a
terrible start I can't trust
by the way his his proper pronunciation
is macaron I know and he goes by
macaroni why did it why does he go by
macaron it's so much cooler I I can tell
you why tell me
because uh there was a project that he
and I worked on many years ago that he
is so terribly ashamed of that he
doesn't want Google searches to bring up
that that really awful project so he
formally changed his name to try to
distance himself from it
he probably would be mortified that I
said that but you know
he really is we had a blast in Mexico
right we were right in the middle of
covid we shot a movie called blackout
yeah and it was the number one movie on
Netflix yeah it was for a minute yeah
yeah
um he did a great job on it but we were
it was almost like a a social experiment
it was right in the middle like the
height of covid when everybody thought
you were gonna die
but he was able to pull it off where we
we rented this
two-star hotel in Mexico City
kept all the cast The Crew the staff
everybody had to be in the bubble in the
bubble inside this thing we we built out
the top two floors for set one was like
a hotel or I'm sorry one was a a
hospital and the other one was uh
uh I forget what what they dressed that
out as but then everybody stayed in the
rooms below that and they had the chefs
and everything stayed in-house the food
was absolutely terrible
I was thinking we're going to Mexico the
food's gonna be great and it was like
worse than jail slop
really yeah but
it was almost it was it was so uh like I
said almost a social experiment because
we all lived together so if we'd have an
idea we'd get together every night and
we'd talk about what we're doing gonna
do the next day we'd go up to the set
and we do we like work things out and
we'd go in the next day and do it it was
like living on the set of a movie yeah
I'm very very literally yeah and it
worked and it really worked because we
were able to do things much more
efficiently
any amount of time we had yeah
um Sam macaroni of course was the
director yes of that movie I I've known
him for for the longest time and uh his
move to be a big director like it was
all hinged on this and I remember like
when he was uh just agonizing over
getting the leading man and who's you
know and I mean when he landed you like
that really wow that feels good you know
he got kind of you know I hate to say it
because Netflix is such a juggernaut but
his movie the one that he turned in was
a really cool sort of quirky uh off-beat
version of it
they took it and turned it into a
straight action movie
and I felt terrible for him because he
poured his heart out you know editing if
you've directed anything it's like you
and you have yeah it's like you put
everything you have into that edit you
know you shoot everything you can and
the amount of time you've got and then
you just pour over the edit and and it
completely changed it on him I I get
that and at the same time I think that
they understand their business like
pretty well and whatever changes they've
made to it
um evidently worked pretty well because
it Shot the movie to the first place
yeah yeah listen they do they definitely
know what they're doing yeah they
definitely do I mean they've got all the
algorithms and all the research behind
it so they know like what exactly is
going to hit to what demographic right
um but his was like this cool quirky
like yeah I get it and I think that uh
hindsight being 2020 that everybody
involved is is Happy it went the way it
went yeah and and that like because you
work for Netflix don't you I I don't but
uh but but you know even with streamers
the movies it's just high stakes
gambling yeah you know it's high stakes
gambling and when you do a project
uh that that project is is your only
shot at getting another project yeah you
know for a lot of people yeah he did so
well with house guests he did so well
with house guests and then that bumped
him up to the next level to get like a
real like legit leading man he's a good
director he really is and I love his
energy he's got the best energy he's
like that 24 7. yeah he really is I
don't know how he does it honestly yeah
it it's incredible so um so so now we've
got
uh the new buddy games and and it's
just departure yeah it really is well
we're trying to be like you
uh this movie is uh based on the first
movie was based on something my buddies
and I do every year called the buddy
games where we get together every third
weekend of August and have a weekend of
games from Wiffle ball to ping pong to
golf
and then we always throw in one or two
crazy ass games like one year it was uh
human bowling where we had this giant
probably probably you know inspired by
some of the jackass stuff you guys did
later on it became more and more crazy
but we had this giant human bowling
where he put this giant piece of this
queen down on this hill and you go
running and you go down you have to try
to take out as many of these garbage
cans as you can and meanwhile
everybody's got rubber or water balloons
to Chuck at you along the way and that
was one of them another year it was you
had to stand there in your underwear
with a helmet on the other guy got to
stand about 20 yards away with a with a
paintball gun and shoot and if you
Flinch and you hear the
you'd lose points and some of the some
of the video that we got from that I
mean this this whole thing is based on
you know these you know when I'm
middle-aged men who for one weekend out
of the Year get to go act like 16 year
olds again
um our wives hate it but it it keeps us
young in a weird way sure and the movie
is based on that it's based on these
guys it's it's really based on the
friendship and the camaraderie and the
Brotherhood that these guys have and uh
you know from that comes absolute
debauchery yeah and this movie is no
different yeah this guy Vinnie over here
uh then maybe not quite middle-aged but
but uh he likes to keep himself young we
we just had him on tour and and he put
together a big package of various items
and stuffed it right up his butt
it keeps me young oh man
it's like it's like a cleanse I guess
keep it cool and clean the batteries
that keeps me charted up is it still up
there no no thank God it's been a bunch
of episodes where we've just celebrated
what was called the prison pocket okay
where he actually you know had to go to
the prison pocket being his [__] yeah
yeah big time
and he had a heroin habit at the time so
when he surrendered to go to jail he
went in with a bunch of stuff up his
butt and we've been so fascinated by it
we've talked about it so much we'll
leave it alone
like can you do a demo
celebrate you getting into Australia oh
man it's just so much fun yeah it's
amazing it's my rocket ship yeah I mean
maybe that maybe that's the next Buddy
game
sounds like Josh's buddies know how to
have a good time and I can relate
because I'm real good at having a good
time and a good time only gets better
with Bluetooth tablets because dude it's
got the same active ingredient as both
Viagra and Cialis except it's a fraction
of the price and I'm telling you
something about this it's a lot of fun
and man it makes my relationship with my
lady a lot more fun candidly plus uh you
can get an entire month's supply of
these awesome Bluetooth tablets which
are now actually more delicious than
ever I've noticed and you can get that
entire month's Supply completely for
free all you pay is five bucks for
shipping man what a deal so to get this
deal go to bluetooth.com and use the
promo code Stevo for the prescription
too you take care of that on the website
in a couple minutes easy with their
medical provider right on the website
that's bluetooth.com and with the promo
code Stevo an entire month supply
absolutely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping so jump on that deal
and let's get back to it
are these characters in the movie based
on like your buddies yeah did you match
them up for the base I mean Nick
swardson's character is is pretty
closely uh based on one of my best
friends Chad Bjork who I've known since
kindergarten um
uh funny really funny super talented
dude uh always always like on the verge
of of success but just not hasn't quite
made it yet and uh that's vendor uh we
call him broken man in the second movie
or he gets named that by this woke uh
cult that we get captured by so uh his
name is broken man we've got Kevin
Dillon they call him uh beef chimney
and we've got Dan back at all who's
swollen tick but you know this this the
second movie is really
uh social commentary in a lot of ways on
some of the
extremes of the uh woke idea stuff going
on
and we did it in a fun way a way that's
not mean-spirited it's all good-hearted
but it you know I thought you know why
not this is this is
some of the stuff is really funny uh and
and I felt like it was ripe for the
picking sure and you directed this yeah
as well as the first one yes and and is
that your uh
is that your first directing roles yeah
yeah the first buddy games was my first
one and this is my second I've done a
couple TV things since then but yeah it
was uh with Disney plus yeah I did uh
Mighty Ducks right an episode of that
um I have another one I'm gonna be doing
in in uh hopefully you know pending the
writer strike
uh this fall called preschool about
these two dads who are fighting to get
their their child into the last spot in
this prestigious La preschool and it's
uh it's not as as R-rated as the buddy
games movies but it's a fun it's a fun
and funny uh
uh expose on you know life as a parent
trying to get your kid into a preschool
how different is being on set when
you're the just an actor or actor
director is there a difference I mean
obviously but like how much more
complicated is that it just makes it it
you know it's like a
I I I got into it because I really
always felt like I wanted to do it it
was something that I always felt like it
would have a knack for but never really
had the confidence to to do it because I
didn't feel like I knew enough
but as I got further along in this
business I knew that I didn't have to
know everything I just needed a good
group of people around me to help sort
of make it work and and let them do
their thing and and the acting part on
camera is probably the part I like the
least because
I've never been so ill-prepared as an
actor as I am when I'm directing because
you're not thinking about it until it's
like time maybe that's a good thing
because you're you're not thinking about
it so much but it is not it's not my
favorite thing because you can't see the
monitor you're sitting there on the
screen with other actors
acting while you're going wait I got to
adjust that I gotta adjust this and
you're not really
fully in the scene like you should be I
would imagine that being the director as
well as an actor that you'd be kind of
self-conscious
because when you're an actor you can
have a relationship with the director
where it's understood hey if you don't
like what you're seeing you tell me yeah
you know like if you be honest and don't
sugarcoat it you know like yeah get the
best out of me yep yep and when you're
the director you're like uh you don't
have anybody there but I did have Rachel
thaley who's been my right hand uh she
helped write this last one actually
along with Gabe McKinley uh
I trust her you know I'm like you've got
to tell me if I sucked in that last take
please if there's if there's things that
that I need to do better tell me you're
not gonna hurt my feelings right because
I don't have any way to know I am
sitting there on you know and as an
actor you're there and you don't know
until the director tells you right but
if you're directing it the only person
that can tell me is me
so you need somebody on the behind the
monitor that can tell you when you suck
which is often what's it like direct
directing somebody like Nick Swardson is
he
was there a lot of times where he's like
going off script improving because to me
he's like you probably want him to be a
legend all day every day he goes off
screen yeah yeah
and that's what I love about him Nick
Swardson you know what I'm sure you know
right for sure yeah we had him on here
oh yeah he's he's just he's one of my
best friends I just love that guy dearly
he uh he does he goes off he goes off
script all day and in fact he'll come
he'll come on Daisy's not even working
and
and uh
just just to be there to help punch up
scenes he's that invested in it and he
stays really sharp during during
production and and he comes out oh my
God that dude he comes up with some of
the most raunchy [__] there's a scene
where I oftentimes like to really
I don't I don't think we can he's like
just do it it's comedy you gotta go hard
I'm like okay I trust you and he did
this thing there's a scene in the movie
where we've been taken sort of captive
by the this this cultist sort of
tribe of people
and they we realize they're not going to
let us go and he he's like just let us
go I will suck all your dicks and eat
all your [__] you don't even have to
shower I'll just go down I'm like whoa
but that's Nick Swardson in a in a
nutshell that guy goes he goes he goes
dark can you find any of his improv to
fit better than the actual script yeah
oh all the time yeah this stuff is
usually better than anything we would
have written yeah you know and that he's
a really good comic writer yeah he's
like if you buy me a drink I'll munch
your box for a week yes yes that's just
like yeah that was all Nick yeah yeah
what about the uh the scene when uh he
had the boner it was that do you have
buddies I mean was that based off of
that was mine actually that was my idea
and he went for it but you know he makes
it all the stuff about like
uh what do you say this is uh
that's called the an erection that's
what boys get when they wake up in the
morning is your is your [__] hard yeah
that was good no it's all Nick you know
and and thank God he does it because he
we want this thing to be hard-hitting
you know I love comedies that are
Unapologetic and and they go hard in the
paint and he brings that he really does
yeah I did for sure I don't know if you
remember the first movie there was a
scene where we had this the he there was
this he was trying to make money that so
he could
he could because I made up this excuse
not to have him at the buddy games and
we had to
I told him that this year there's an
entry fee he's like okay fine what is it
40 bucks like there's 10 000 bucks he's
like are you kidding me I can't so
there's a whole montage of him raising
the money to be able to come and he goes
to this there's he Parks his van across
the street from these little girls who
have a lemonade stand
and he starts talking [__] to them back
and forth and he says he goes he says
what do you say to him uh
you both you're both could be strippers
when you grow up really bad ones that no
one pays to see
and it was so great because of these two
innocent girls that you know nobody
would get away with except for that dude
yeah you know he's just like he he for
whatever reason we forgive him for his
his crazy Shenanigans yeah he's genius
is it true that we read that you were
studying to be a dentist yes
your childhood dream to become a dentist
well it wasn't I don't know it was a
dream it was it was an aspiration of as
a dream why what about the mouth pretty
early on I don't I think this is this is
the reason I think I was always good at
drawing and making things with my hands
like clay and you know painting and
things like that
and my mother was at an early age was
pushing me to see what I was going to be
when I grew up I'm like I'm a freshman I
don't know
in high school
and by my sophomore actually earlier she
was pressing me I was like I don't know
I'm just a pro athlete that quickly
didn't materialize but
I came up with the idea to be a dentist
because I could use my abilities with my
hands my artistic you know whatever
and I could call myself a doctor
and that would make her happy and I
didn't have the same sort of stress that
you would have as a normal doctor and to
make Mom happy and and I really I I I
would go I got my degree in biology
went to minor State University got that
degree which was not easy
uh
went and observed a bunch of different
dentists took the DAT which is like the
MCAT but for dentists and then moved to
California you know
telling my mom that I was going to go to
dentals I was going to apply to dental
school but meanwhile I think I always
wanted to do what we're doing now
and I didn't tell her and then once I
got my first job on All My Children
she forgot about the dentist thing and
she was fine with me being on a soap
yeah
than the first job
you say all my children but but you're
going right past the male model
that came right that came really a
little earlier but you know that I was I
mean male model of the Year beating
Ashton Kutcher it's a pretty big deal
it's been sort of blown out of
proportion though because yes I won male
model of the year at this imta
convention in New York which is like a
bunch of aspiring I got I got asked to
go to this thing
and I was fresh out of North Dakota I
was living in Sacramento this this this
agent at the time asked me to go to this
thing and they would pay they would
sponsor me to go I was like hell yeah
I've never been in New York I'll do that
it was like 1500 bucks to to get in so I
went
um and after a few days there was the
buzz around the whole thing was that oh
it's between you and you and this this
kid from wherever and then this kid from
Iowa which was Chris Couture at the time
and then it came down to this this uh
Chris Kutcher yeah his real name was
Chris Kutcher wow okay I don't know if
he wants me to say that I mean
I love Ashton but that was his name at
the time and I think I'm sure he's Rich
he doesn't care he's real he's doing
just fine yeah but he uh I probably
don't have to tell you this but Ashton
Kutcher is doing just fine because he's
a businessman and I'm also a businessman
and a large part of the reason why I'm
doing just fine it's ship station
because I built an audience online and I
sell products to them awesome products
like Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole these are the best butt wipes
you can possibly get and how do you get
them get them at stevo.com and when you
order them I get a little label prints
out in my warehouse my warehouse guys
take that label and it tells them to put
butt wipes for your butthole in the
package they put the label on the
package and the package goes to you and
it is so simple because ship station
brings in all the various ways of
selling if it's Etsy Amazon your own
website it all comes right into this
interface along with all the ways of
shipping stuff FedEx United States
Postal Service UPS I mean it's all there
and they give you the best rates that
are normally reserved for Fortune 500
companies and if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo you get to try it all out for six
months free trial totally for free and
it's risk free so there's nothing to
lose and there's everything to gain so
you could be like Ashton Kutcher and
your boy Stevo if you learn how to take
advantage of this internet world and
e-commerce and the way to do that is
with ship station so for your 60-day
free trial one more time go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo it's time to make ship happen baby
now let's get back to it
it became like the bus was who's going
to be me or this kid and and it became
this it was almost like a beauty pageant
we walked the runway in our underwear we
did like this we had breakfast just so
ridiculous I look back at it now and you
know you say do you have any regrets and
most people say I don't regret anything
well I regret that I mean I wouldn't
have brought it up if I just didn't find
it so unbelievably awesome that you were
a male model so close to the time that
Zoolander came out
it was like I was like Miss America they
were holding me up they should put sash
across my a TR or the whole thing but it
was uh it was I did I won you know it
was like third runner-up is whoever and
then second or first runner-up is and
we're both waiting on pins and needles
Chris Couture and I was like oh my God
I don't know there's a bunch of guys
there uh but it but the the best part
about the story is that right after that
I wanted he took second and he went on
to like major stardom right away 70s
Show That 70s Show he did a big Calvin
Klein thing he was like Dude Where's My
Car yeah he did a bunch of stuff and
meanwhile I didn't get anything for like
five years I was so pissed I was like
but I'm male model of the year
and I had to like I had to like Beat the
Streets and and and and I modeled like
after that for maybe maybe a year
because I was really bad at it and never
got comfortable you know taking photos
it was never something I was very good
at I wanted to do TV commercials and and
where I could actually do something yeah
and and when did All My Children start
uh that started in let's see I won the
that in 97 moved to LA I was in I was
living in San Francisco at the time
uh and then moved to LA lived with my
buddies there for a little bit started
taking you know really getting into as
about the time I'd foregone dental
school and really wanted to get into
acting
and uh I got all my children I think in
so about a year and a half of beating
the streets in LA and and ended up
getting this this gigs which made me
then move back to New York
so I was there for three years
um
the uh the commercials thing
was is something that you really hung on
to um macaroni told us that now you've
got like a whole company that just makes
commercials yeah we have a company
called Dakota media that does
you know as I'm sure you guys get you
know people they want you to take a
photo with whatever new water or
whatever new
thing is out there and I was like well
we could do better if we're gonna if I'm
gonna sell myself out to do this stuff
let's make it cool and interesting and
consumable for people that are watching
it and it doesn't look like that
straight up I'm getting paid to hold
this drink okay so the idea came from
that and we started shooting this we
shot one of them was Hyundai and we we
said well we're gonna go out and we're
gonna actually shoot something so we
shot this whole two-day shooting this
little commercial for it which led to
the next one which led to the next one
and now we're doing uh a lot of really
cool stuff mostly in sports now
it's like branded storytelling it's not
so much commercials as it is like uh
who does a good job of it uh Yeti does a
really good job of this stuff is is sort
of telling a story with Yeti kind of in
the background and so that's kind of
what we do Matt
go get a goddamn thing right not one
are there I guess you could call them
commercials and I would trust me if we
got if we got like a you know a Cadillac
commercial we'd be happy to go shoot
that but mostly it's we do a lot of
stuff for Bobcat uh
we just did a really cool thing for the
LA Rams and the draft or around the
draft yeah
um and then we've got some other we got
Tampa Bay Lightning is another one of
their our clients and we've got some
other stuff that's that's coming up
that's fun and I just I you know for me
I love the the development the creative
side of it coming up with ideas then
figuring out how to shoot it and then
going and shooting it and you know all
the process of making something it keeps
you sharp I think
um and it it keeps you uh creative and
it was a it's a good way to
to sort of keep doing stuff that I love
yeah for sure
and uh so you said that the Rams and
and and the lightning lightning yeah and
and that's right in your wheelhouse
right you're all about the sport yeah
I'm a big sports fan uh I'm a big
Vikings fan like Nick
um why the Vikings
I'm from North Dakota so it's like uh
you know it's that's the team you root
for yeah it's them or the Packers and
I'm certainly not going to root to the
Packers right not a chance
um yeah I've been Nick definitely likes
the Vikings oh yes he does he is he is
the number one fan I believe yeah big
time and um you were a quarterback in
college I was I was Steve you did your
homework for this a little bit yeah I
was I was uh I played quarterback at
Minot State University the in the town
that I grew up at the time we were NAIA
division two
uh
uh thought I was going to be a
professional athlete and then realized I
wasn't nearly athletic enough
uh but but yeah it was my that was my
you know growing in North Dakota there's
not much else to do in the winter
especially and you're tall yeah I played
a lot of hockey growing up too and I
just got too tall and skinny
I've been very very uh vocal about how
attractive Tom Brady is and you might be
an even better looking quarterback hey
I'll take it what was your uh what was
your um like uh the most yards you've
ever passed forward in a game in in
college or what was your best game um
probably not not much more than 300
yards I mean my my but that was not
often we were we were uh short passing
kind of a West Coast offense kind of
thing but my freshman year I'll never
forget it was like this is when I
thought like oh my God
that I'm gonna I I I'm going to the
league
I got put in in the fourth quarter as a
freshman and I threw for I think three
or four touchdowns in like 210 yards or
something one quarter yeah it was like I
couldn't they were just everything I
threw up they would catch yeah and it
was one of those games that you know you
never see again you know and I was
probably going against the fourth string
defense at the time so but I don't like
to you know leave that part of the story
in what's what's up what's the hardest
what's the hardest you've ever been hit
as a quarterback do you have a a time
where you just got your back oh God many
times you know do you ever play football
that was the Long Snapper and I quit
Okay so that's all I know then I played
water polo well I I remember that for me
it was like there's a couple there's a
one time in high school and then another
time in college where I for sure had a
concussion because I remember getting
hit and I remember seeing perfectly
shaped stars like in a circle and it was
like
and at the time there was no concussion
protocol it was just like get back in
the game rub some dirt on it and get out
there uh and then again in college my
mom
my mom was in the stands and I remember
just got crushed by this big D end and
uh
and I remember hearing my mom in the
audience go oh
yeah
and those are the I mean I I was one of
those quarterbacks who avoided contact
at all costs I was always trying to I
was like a you slipped straight up
pocket passer you know I wasn't I wasn't
uh you know
one of these one of these quarterbacks
now that can run and take hits and do
the whole thing I avoided that I think
Dan Marino in his career rushed for a
negative number of yardage yeah yeah
that was me basically
yeah Steve what's the hardest you've
ever been hit that you saw oh God you
ever seen Stars
or do you just passed straight out
yeah I mean like I think that the most
uh clearly I was knocked unconscious
was uh on that treadmill in the last
jackass maybe that's because we're older
you know turns out you get older it's a
lot easier to knock you out but that of
your whole career that's the one well
when I was in the WWE match like I don't
remember leaving the ring really yeah it
was uh you had a concussion probably it
was 2006. we were reporting the second
Jackass movie and and and so we got this
we're doing this match and Chris Pontius
and I but I didn't know about wrestling
and I didn't know that that you're
supposed to like play dead like when the
for the match to be over yeah and my
natural sort of thing when I get hit I
react yeah I need to get back up yeah so
so like what was supposed to be the
final thing like the the Samoan
bulldozer this huge wrestler 300 and
some pounds jumps off the top rope and
does what's called a splash he lands
right on me and I'm rolling around like
oh
and that this is offensive to the
wrestler because I'm that's not protocol
right you're supposed to It's supposed
to just lay still yeah like it's over it
was rashiki right it was uh yeah yeah
and so because I was kept moving around
this was offensive to him and so he had
to keep yeah and he just kept and and he
kept I'm thinking it's supposed to be
over so I'm like like stops but I'm
still moving around so I need to keep
going he's hitting you in the face he
she dropped his elbow on me that was so
brutal I don't remember like I don't
remember leaving the ring they didn't
even show the end like it got so dark
and they they just the logo came in and
they went to commercial oh in the middle
I like uh they didn't it didn't end and
what's the next thing you remember
there's no footage of me leaving the
ring and I don't remember leaving the
ring and and so yeah that would probably
be the hardest ever oh my God what do
you remember next I remember the next
thing I remember I was in like a control
room
uh Chris Pontius uh describes that we
were in this control room and Vince
McMahon was in there like yeah that was
great yeah
but yeah
interesting yeah you must have taken
some serious hits though on all the
stuff you guys have done over the years
I mean there's there's been there's been
some dude I'm the first special guilty
as charged when Tim Kennedy dropped me
on my head you played that off good but
like I mean I remember you he you did it
the first time and it didn't look cool
and then before you went on on stage a
second time you're like make sure he
drops me on my head
and then he walks out and then and then
Tim's like what did he say and I'm like
he said make sure you do it harder next
time and drop him on his head and he's
like this is a good day
at the time I think he was the top 10
ranks he's top five heavyweight UFC
fighter really and it was who Tim
Kennedy Tim Kennedy
the bit was that cut a lemon in half
squeeze all the lemon juice in my eyes
and then get chunked unconscious and
dropped on my head
but during the special she Lifted Me Up
feet off the ground and got me
completely unconscious and just dropped
me from up there oh my God I had bounced
like a basketball after you're so lucky
you're still with us and he was out for
like 10 15 seconds during the filming of
the special then I hopped up and kept on
with the ACT
yeah yeah you didn't even feel your eyes
burning you know that's true that's a
crazy thing it's the lemon juice when I
got up that's wild and then at the end
of that Sam macaroni tasered him while
they are asking him questions that yeah
Sam Akron is really a good friend of
mine and
clearly friends like me yeah
he was going to
um like set myself on fire and and
something else but they really really
shut that down at the theater so I
needed an alternate like big like stun
ending for the for the ACT and as
hurricane will get uh like a shot with a
taser with the actual wires and the arms
the ones that the police use that go in
and then now for the ones that police
years it it gives you 50 000 Volts for
five seconds
and then the police can hit it again and
add more five seconds but
the Tim Kennedy told me he said I I
wasn't able to get the the law
enforcement kind I got the civilian kind
which is different in that when you
shoot it goes for 30 seconds the idea
being that like a like a woman can shoot
her attacker drop the thing and run yeah
and it continues it just goes for 30
seconds to give 30 seconds to get away
from your attacker and so I was like oh
man 30 seconds
when we arrived at is there it would be
a 30-second q a hosted by Sam macaroni
did well I did it was great I I was
worried that 30 seconds it was just
gonna get kind of boring you know like
they're just the same thing for 30
seconds so we made it a q a and it was
yeah a q a while you were getting tased
yeah yeah 30 seconds of me being
100. do you remember what he asked
my God I thank God what is your name uh
how big is your dick
there's uh like these are silly
questions but it was really funny oh my
God yeah that was fun yeah Steve you are
a legend dude I mean it man I I would
never have
the balls that you've had do you still
want to do that kind of stuff or does it
over you past it now like now I
incorporate I mean at that time that was
my first comedy special and it was me me
performing stand up and then
intermittently doing stunts on stage
that were kind of organic to the ACT
yeah and then
um my next comedy special was was
telling stories and and with the footage
of the stories edited into it and then
now I'm getting ready to tape my third
comedy special which I filmed all new
stuff and I tell the stories and show
the footage but you didn't actually have
to go do it again I don't do it or
anything like that
but you actually go and do still do some
of this crazy stuff
I mean tell them what we have planned
next the tits yeah the name the next one
after I tape this next special
which is the bucket list special then I
start putting together the Stevo's gone
too far to her and that one is me
confronting my middle age lashing out at
father time yeah see that like I've got
dimples developing actually I already
have dimples under my man boobs this is
just what happens your body starts oh I
know dude I know and I'm so mad that
that father time has given me man boobs
that I'm gonna go and try and get them
Double D's wait with proper breast
surgery you're gonna get breast implants
yeah
I'll only keep them for like three
months you know like so I can film all
the all the bits the vignettes yeah for
the tour
but yeah like I've got you know
my wrinkling going on like my face is
sitting there I don't want anyone there
noticing it so I gotta get a big dick
tattooed on my forehead so that's all
anybody sees wait so you're really gonna
do actual dick tattooed I'll end up
getting it lasered off but yeah I'm
gonna properly get it still yeah that's
a lot of pain to endure so I gotta cut
you open and put breasts in and then I
do and so many people are trying to talk
me out of getting like who boob jobs
just people comments from people and
then there's something that absolutely
nobody is trying to talk me out of doing
which is being thoughtful and
considerate about the environment by
drinking liquid death why is it so good
for the environment because it's all an
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans not
plastic which is destroying the world
you heard about that big plastic Island
right yeah it's very real and liquid
death started out with the mountain
spring water and the sparkling water
then the flavor flavored water now
they've got these epic
19.2 fluid
ounce cans of tea iced tea super healthy
full of vitamins not a lot of sugar
absolutely delicious this is the
convicted melon oh sorry this is rest in
Peach you got the armless Palmer I mean
this company is the greatest and if you
ordered this tea from liquid death on
Amazon or some of your local retailers
you can get free shipping which is crazy
plus listeners of the Wild Ride podcast
can get 20 off of your first order of
apparel at liquiddeath.com if you use
slash Stevo that's
liquiddeath.com
Stevo for 20 off of your first order of
apparel and if you haven't seen liquid
death apparel it's epic it's hilarious
it's epic the social media for this
company is like I think they're the most
followed beverage drink like I don't
know what I mean dude they're killing it
so support liquid death by going to
liquiddeath.com Stevo buying the tea on
Amazon your local retailers to support
this company man liquiddeath.com now
let's get back to it and then they don't
understand that the more they try to
tell me not to do it yeah
it's awesome
the first the first person who I uh
voiced my plan to right when I came up
with the idea was Nick Swardson I said
to him on the podcast it was like
episode number nine in 2020. I said dude
I'm gonna get tits and he goes
the whole thing is just like uh the
theme of it is confronting my middle age
lashing out and uh kind of you know it
feels a little bit like a last hurray
you know but but then again I don't know
I don't think I can stop being an
attention [__] Josh how did you
confront middle age differently than
Steve would approach it uh I try to take
a more holistic approach yeah
yeah tell us about the yoga how often do
you that uh well like you I am now a
middle-aged man 50 years old and you
know it's it's it's a it's a hard truth
to you know
to come to terms with and
but at the same time I think part of the
reason is these movies help you know
keep that kid alive but personally it's
like you know yoga and it's
ice bass and it's acting like an idiot
with my buddies and and like my dad said
don't let the old man in the door
and that's that's a good that's a that
really stuck with me it's like he's he's
right don't let the old man in the door
because once you do you become that
thing that you're sort of avoiding and
I'm not going to get man boobs
but I do I do work hard at trying to
avoid the you know that inevitable yeah
uh an inevitable you know breast thing
that happened to all of us they just
start to hang yeah it sucks
um it's actually a really good idea
yeah
I mean like secretly I'm kind of happy
that uh
the world's most famous plastic surgeon
Terry Dubrow of the show botched okay
this guy fixes everything he's just the
best there is and I talked to him about
the idea and he said oh I wouldn't put
him in but but uh I could take him out
and like you know to the extent that
like taking him out and kind of did do
his thing I I could end up so what are
you gonna get him put in somewhere in
Mexico I don't know who's gonna do that
I'm sure that's uh Scott's job yeah we
can find something you guys seen the
dude on Instagram I forget his name but
he has the butt implant he does all the
crazy stuff is that the guy who was
always like jogging he's jogging
that's a real UFC implant I think so
yeah I don't know if it is but you're
talking about the guy who's like he's he
did the UFC fight too yeah yeah he's
really funny I know he's not a fighter
he's just like a social media influencer
yeah but he has like these butt implants
yeah the videos are like really really
good he always wear these really tight
pants with a with a apple bottom yeah
wow it looks pretty good
are you are you a big UFC fan yes huge
huge UFC fan yeah we're heading out
there this this week who fights this
week Angela Hill and Mackenzie Dern okay
I uh I'm friends with Angela Hill okay
yeah we actually um commentated for uh
another MMA organization cage Warriors
okay and uh I thought she was on that
with you yeah she was we were on the you
had a lot of fun doing that I had a
blast I think I might do it again on
June 2nd where cage Warriors down in San
Diego Angela Hill I'm trying to figure
out who that is again Angela Hill she's
she's been prolific
I should know this as I do I literally
watch every one of them that comes out
I'm trying to remember yeah she got
robbed recently McKenzie durn's the Jiu
Jitsu girl cute yeah
is it Andrew is it Angie Overkill Angie
Overkill oh wait
yep Angie Overkill okay yeah I do know
who she is she's great yeah I love her
damn she's badass yeah um so we're
hitting a fight this weekend yeah we are
dude yeah I talked to Dana the other day
did you uh did you see the last Luke
rockhold bare knuckle fight I didn't but
uh I saw him after yeah he took he took
a broken teeth broke two of his teeth or
three of his teeth I mean that stuff is
no joke that's dark the thing is like
okay you're gonna go bare knuckle fight
Mike Perry like you know he's not going
down no the other guy's not going down
it's like I was thinking about the other
days like when you have a serving job
like [__] I gotta go to work and serve
these [__] it's like you know once
you're going into those fights like you
are gonna like your face is gonna be so
[__] up yeah my wife is like but
rockhold is so cute why is he doing that
right he is you know and she was and she
was like she was like upset by the fact
that this dude was getting in the ring I
was like easy easy
model in the 90s too
[Music]
Loma fights tonight right where is that
all right I guess this probably won't be
on tonight
lomachenko fights uh Haney tonight in
Vegas I think Loma chicka I don't know
if you follow boxing at all but
lomachenko means
the most talented I've ever seen yeah
wow as far as his skill set yeah I don't
really care too much about boxing
because whenever I try to watch it it
seems like they're hugging each other
yeah I'm not a huge fan either I'm much
more of a UFC fan because the stakes are
so much higher and the skill level right
the disciplines these guys have is just
and and weirdly the sportsmanship the
respect you know you don't see a lot of
that in sports now in in the UFC these
guys you know they beat the crap out of
each other but they still have a mutual
respect that I just I think is so cool
like sharing a ring together yeah right
no matter who gets beat who you know no
matter how much they hate each other
before yeah afterwards like I mean
there's like a certain thing right
usually yeah normally for the most part
we saw something or I saw something that
uh that really piqued my interest that
you described having a near-death
experience it didn't seem like it was
the kind of variety where you left your
body and and yeah because because we're
we're super into that yeah have you ever
seen the accounts of people who like
they die they have this experience going
through the white light and the Life
review and all this and then they come
back to their box yeah like man we're
into that yeah yeah I read a book called
what was it called
any Masters or
it was about
The Hobbit I can't find what they called
it now but it's like basically your body
you you leave the body in in their their
they're able to sort of fly around and
see things from from different angles
yeah right I can't remember what it's
called now uh
uh Astro astral astro Projection that's
what it is yeah read a book on that and
that was crazy to me it's like I think
that's different than the near-death
experience phenomenon
what was yours like well mine wasn't
mine was not that but it it was I've had
a couple
both in both around the ocean uh growing
up in North Dakota we're about as far
from any ocean as you can get so I'm not
I'm more of a land mammal than I'm a
ocean dweller
uh but I was in Brazil uh which one are
you talking about the one in Brazil I
I yeah
take it out by way oh yeah yeah so that
was in uh well the first one was in
Brazil many years ago we were shooting a
movie called Teresa's there and I
decided to go out body surfing with
these dudes from California and I got
and I get out there too far and I'm
trying to you know I learned that I'm
supposed to swim underneath the wave and
you know let it sort of duck dive yeah
duck dive well I wasn't able to get
close enough to it to dive under it and
it hit me got tumbled got tumbled got
tumbled finally got my way back up to
the shore boom Another one hits me and
and
I remember just going oh my God this is
it I can't I'm gonna drown right now and
I remember just fighting my way fighting
my way and I finally felt felt sand
beneath my feet and I was able to walk
back to Shore and when I got back I was
I was I was so spent so much adrenaline
dumped that my body like completely I
had to lay there for like 20 minutes
before I could get up anymore I've never
felt so incapacitated in my whole life
that was the first time and then the one
you're talking about was uh
we're in the Dominican uh on a movie
called uh shotgun wedding and and uh
that we're in this Cove this beautiful
Cove that had this you know a few days
earlier it was really calm and I was I
jumped off the cliff and went and swim
they freaked out they didn't want me to
do it but I was like it's just a calm
little Cove well a few days later it was
really turbulent I mean it was like this
fish bowl just
waves just crashing up against this
thing and they hit the Rocks they fly 50
feet in the air I was just mesmerized by
this so I thought I'd go like video it
in slow motion just to show well this
Rogue Wave comes up and with all this
this razor rock all around it was like
super sharp Rock
and this wave and I have it on video
where this wave comes up and hits and
comes over the top and you see this
thing coming and had I not been stopped
by this razor Rock I would have been
washed out and I don't know how they
ever would have
so you got all caught up I got all I got
really caught up
um and it's right in the middle of
shooting so it was like thankfully I had
a bandage on my hand anyway from the
prop uh in it and I had a big hole in my
hand from
uh trying to brace myself but it was uh
that one could have easily had I not
been
you know stopped by the rock I'd have
been washed out I don't know how they
would have ever and it's it's
interesting to me like had you
um been really hurt then that would have
presumably uh voided the insurance on
you for the movie right like isn't that
like I think so you get insured yeah I
remember when we started doing jackass
uh oh I can't how do they ever insure
those movies by the way that's a good
question and I I don't know that they
did
um I think that the first Jackass movie
was uh
recall negative pickup okay I think they
created like a ghost company that maybe
didn't even exist on paper and like
shuttled the money to it and then we
filmed the movie and once nobody died
then Paramount found out about it
so you never really had to insure it I
don't know and that would have if
there's anything like that going on it
was only for the first movie yeah I it
was it was by the time the third movie
came around
um I had gotten clean and sober
I asked for the first time hey what
happens if somebody really gets hurt or
killed and they said oh they hadn't
dawned on you before then
the answer was standard workman's comp
California Workman's comp laws apply in
that situation huh and I was like
all right cool mates
yeah yeah I didn't really know what that
means but
um but I don't think we necessarily
um kind of go by the standard rules yeah
but when we started
Knoxville was shooting a a movie for
Disney called big trouble okay and um
he was
seriously not allowed to do any
dangerous stuff yeah while he was on
contract for that movie like he all he
was doing was like the the fake baby you
know like would put the fake baby on the
roof of the car and then drive away all
like all like the low impact yeah or no
impact like men on the street pranks
because because he's shooting moves
sorry I can just imagine oh when you're
like I don't I don't know if we've had
like an actual leading man A-list
celebrity this is exciting man what like
I thought you're talking about Knoxville
yeah but Knoxville like uh oh come on
now yeah I've seen I've seen the show
you guys have had we've had some good
guests yeah you spot that light on real
proper Leading Men movie stars whoa yeah
I haven't been called that I appreciate
that how's it working with somebody like
Shia LaBeouf
you know I love that I love Shia he's uh
clearly insanely talented um
[Music]
and uh I think misunderstood a lot I
think he gets a bad rap I think he does
have
you know when he's not drinking he's
much more yeah level and I think that
he'd probably be the first one to admit
it um but he you know he I just I I I've
known him since he was
a kid you know the first the first
Transformers movie
I'll never forget he's just such a wild
card and that's what methink makes him
so great is he shows up at LAX we're
flying to Mexico and white Alamogordo
New Mexico
and this I think the first time I
actually met him and he shows up with a
black eye and we're supposed to start
shooting like two days later
I was like dude what happened he's like
all these punks said I was at a Dodger
game last night and these guys started
talking [__] so I you know I got I was
like he's down you can't do that man
but he is fearless he is truly Fearless
he's uh you know I got nothing but love
for him yeah do you keep in touch with
him uh last time I reached out I never
heard back
so I don't know I don't know I don't
know what he's up to now and then you're
currently on a in a movie with uh Mel
Gibson on Netflix and uh called Bandit
yeah the girl who was the uh the girl
next door next door Alicia Cuthbert yeah
yeah yeah how's it working with Mel
Gibson he's great he's the best again I
think a little bit misunderstood I know
that he's ruffled a lot of feathers over
the years with
some of the stuff that he's done and
said but uh my experience with him was
great yeah absolute gentleman
uh total Pro you know I didn't see any
of the stuff that that you hear about I
thought that he was fantastic and and by
the way one of the great I was mostly
excited to work with them because he's
just one of the greatest directors of
all time if you think about some of the
stuff he's doing Christ or Braveheart
yeah it's just like it's insane I just
wanted to pick his brain about that like
how did you do that and at a pretty
early age
yeah wow those are giant I mean buddy
games is one thing but Braveheart that's
a whole other Beast did he direct that
yeah yeah wow I also read this early 30s
I think yeah Kurt Russell
when he was doing Tombstone the director
wasn't doing that well so he directed it
and they said a lot of people would have
gave Kurt Russell credit for directing
it but he didn't want his name on it he
gave the guy but I mean something like
Tombstone two directed that and being
the lead who directed
but he helped the story was whoever
directed Tombstone I I don't know what
it would during the headlights or it was
so he pretty much directed it but he was
like I'm not putting my name on this but
everybody on the whole set would have
said he was the director really yeah I
didn't I didn't I've never heard that
yeah do you do social media are you on
Instagram okay yeah yeah I gotta get on
there yeah it's it's it's not as
exciting as yours yeah the last one he
did was snorting a worm oh Jesus
old footage but uh yeah it didn't
perform that well either man
took a nurse worm up the nostril and
then yeah you think that's that's gonna
get yeah yeah A million hits you'd think
that would be money do you have uh plans
to direct anymore
uh yeah I'm supposed to do the movies
preschool I was telling you about uh
sometime after whenever the writer
strike is over we'll be able to do that
but yeah I mean I I really do love doing
it it's just a lot of work yeah it's so
much more work than just going in and
you know punching your time card as an
actor on a movie it's it's like you are
involved from a very Inception all the
way through the delivering into the yeah
and I like that about it I do I like the
the creative input and the shaping of
the story and and being able to sort of
because a lot of the times before I'd be
like
I would be acting in something with some
kid who I didn't have any experience was
like why like I I had the experience but
I didn't think I trusted it you know and
and to to be able to have now done it a
couple times
uh has given me the confidence I guess
to to to trust that I do know enough and
and know enough to know that I don't
have to know everything
um so yeah I I mean I'd love to
do more why do you have a project yeah
it equals
so let me tell you let me ask you about
this so I have uh
well
for various reasons uh
my wife is is not drinking for the next
okay nine months
and I went to Vegas with my buddies last
weekend okay we all went me and my wife
and their my buddies and their wives so
it was I had my spiritual hazmat suit on
me
uh you can't get in trouble that way but
you know I I I I decided after this trip
that I am done with her to with with the
with the drinking too
and I got to admit the last it's been
like four days and I'm not a heavy
drinker but I do like to have a drink
you know once uh you know once a night
like I like a sugar-free Red Bull vodka
around 4 30 maybe another one around 6
30. all right and then I'm usually done
and depending on a couple more shots but
I gotta say that it's you know the these
last couple of days
I've really had this urge to and I was
like I don't have a problem maybe I do
have a problem you know you don't have
to be a fall down drunk I don't think to
to to have a have an issue and I feel
like maybe I do and and I feel like that
alone will enhance my life people that I
know like you
and are you yeah
everybody that I know that's done it Dax
is another one Dax is a good buddy of
mine
uh I played golf with Jason Bateman at
the ATT these guys lives have just like
elevated from it maybe there's something
to that here's the thing
any other disease the best you can hope
for is to get back to as healthy as you
were before you got sick yeah but for us
when we treat our disease we become a
better version of ourselves than we ever
were before yeah it's crazy yeah I see
that a lot and it's just kind of done
I'm in a reason because I I don't have a
drinking problem and I'm not sure I'm up
maybe I am uh but there's clearly
something there that I feel like I want
to explore yeah what the potential is
just taking it out
there's different categories of uh of
drinkers there's uh what's the first one
problem Drinker and
um this is the the person who recognizes
they have a problem and and are able to
moderate or stop all together
I don't remember and then uh and then
one alcoholic by depth and by definition
means that that you you want to stop you
just can't yeah you know you've got this
powerlessness yeah to stop and um I
think it's a little bit as a rule of
thumb
uh if nobody who's not an alcoholic ever
wonders if they're an alcoholic
that could be a rule of thumb mine was
like I was more of like trying to stop
and not and then but I was I was more
resentful of myself for like operating
at like 60 my potential yeah and I felt
like that's where I'm at yeah honestly
yeah on the other hand though like for
example if if you go on any kind of a
diet you know like oh I'm gonna like eat
less yeah like as soon as you decide
you're on a diet all you can think about
is food yeah yeah so the very Act of of
seeking to quit like just makes you
obsessed with it yeah that that uh calls
to mind the saying what you resist will
persist yeah so if you're trying to
resist it then um then that makes it
more difficult yeah and I think that for
us we call it consider it rather than
resisting it we surrender yeah yeah you
know we we uh surrendered and we admit
defeat yeah but it has it has nothing to
do with the alcohol or whatever the vice
places it's like what are you covering
up and so like the very fact of like not
medicating or numbing like the things
that come up yeah are the things that
you have to deal with and then once you
deal with them your life gets better
it's not like oh I quit drinking my life
gets better it's like things are going
to come up in your head where like maybe
you're shoving down you're probably more
able to deal with them yeah but you
don't even know what's coming up because
you're like oh it's I don't have drink
yeah and then exactly cool but then as
it comes up you're like oh [__] what is
that and then you know it might be like
a fear of directing or whatever the next
it's like then what you're like oh wait
what is that then you're like it's
plaguing me and you start talking about
it and then you talk to somebody and
actually have something to do with
something else that you fix that's why
your life gets because the ripple effect
off that root cause is what makes it
better it's like the thing on the desk
the balls that are hanging like you pull
back one ball yeah and then you let it
go but it's actually some like the
fourth ball down that pops up yeah you
know right like what's kicking off isn't
the actual issue it's something
underneath yeah
I always wish I like you know this
alcoholic I am is like I always wish
that I worked the steps of the 12-step
program before I quit drinking so like
my life could have gotten better and I
could have still drank yeah I was always
like why did I do this like when I was
like 18 because then I could still drink
and have a good but like yeah that's not
yeah mine is not mine's never been the
guy who wakes up the morning has to
continue right but it is something that
you know I've become accustomed to
having a drink
and it's and I've realized recently that
it's holding me back you know and it's
and it's it's numbing me out to a point
where I'm not as present as I need to be
or I'm not as creative as I could be
and and you know I'll be a better I'm
hoping because of this and dealing with
the stuff that will come up and it does
it is coming up now because
the last few nights I'm like this is
normally when I go but what I've done is
I've just gone and done yoga instead or
I've gone and worked out instead so I'm
trying to do things to replace that
three hour gap where I would normally be
creating a yeah they say like in the
first couple weeks when you quit
drinking it and you have that urge have
a piece of chocolate because the sugar
is the same sugar that your body's
craving that's why chew on some
chocolate you've heard that too yeah
I've heard that at AAA meetings they
have a lot of cookies and cake around
for that reason huh yeah it's okay you
know so to your point
if I do or you're okay can't remember
whose point now are you drunk yeah maybe
I'm drunk
the uh you know I haven't I haven't been
like I'm done you know because I I know
that if the more I resist it the more
it'll persist
so it's like
I'm just gonna try this till January
and hopefully by that time I'll be
past it and I'll have enough distance
between me and it that I won't need it
and I'm hoping I'm hoping that I get to
a place you know the idea of never
having one again is a little bit freaky
to me but just taking a break from it
for a while and doing the work to
support it I think will help and they uh
that's something that helped me and said
if you imagined you know all of the
laundry that you know for the rest of
your life would be yeah and it has a lot
of laundry but you just do one load at a
time yeah yeah you drink during the
buddy games oh yeah so you probably
think it had like [__] well I'm not
gonna be able to drink at that Buddy
game yeah yeah it's true I mean it's
like you know the lake this I spent a
lot of time at my Lake cabin and there's
always a Busch Light yeah for sure it
sounds like but like it it sounds like
the scariest situation to me because
I consider myself so lucky that it got
as bad as it did that I just had to
address it yeah you know what like the
way that I was could not continue it
just needed to be addressed it was
urgent and as a result because I
addressed it here I've like you know
I've been able to free up so much time
and get super focused and make less
mistakes yeah but do you think you would
have addressed it if they if Knoxville
and them didn't come and I remember that
I was out of gas at the end of The Run
what are you trying to like weren't you
trying to like throw yourself off a
building first thing it was it was all
bad what scares me is the idea of it of
kind of having alcoholism just a little
bit just enough to interfere with
you know like uh your life interfere
with your relationships slow you down
like kind of walking in quicksand a
little bit yeah you know but it's not so
bad that it needs to be addressed so it
just goes on and on and on I feel like I
know people who
have just had years kind of slip through
their fingers and then the years turn
into decades and the next thing I get
old and you're thinking man like yeah
like uh I didn't operate at my Highest
Potential yeah yeah it took me a while
to quit drinking because I was like oh
there's a wedding in two weeks yeah or
there's a friend going away so but
there's always something yeah then again
I think it's worth noting that you're
evidently doing pretty well you know I
think that well it's relative because
he's probably like what's my potential
if I'm doing this well
yeah maybe I mean I I am able to to
accomplish things but I'm not operating
as as efficiently as I should be I could
be you feel like you're eating soup with
a fork yeah kind of I'm still getting
full I'm still doing I'm still like I'm
still getting stuff done but not as
clear-headed as I need to be you know
I'm a little bit slow in the morning or
I'm you know not as present as I should
be as a father which really yeah that
bums me out I'm a good dad but I feel
like it could be a really good dad if I
were yeah how old are you kidnap nine oh
okay you know that's uh yeah I mean that
that that's that's important yeah
um in uh our beverage program the
literature is pretty clear that
um you know if if uh you think you have
a problem like you know but this is how
it works but but you know if you're not
sure then yeah go give it another try
you know but if you find yourself going
around the loop where you you don't want
to drink and you died I went and did it
you know like and and then you're going
then maybe think about like actually
um
to following the path laid out in the
look of the beverage program yeah yeah
you probably didn't see this interview
going this direction whatever it's all
good yeah it seems to happen quite a bit
with us I think yeah like I'm I'm pretty
careful about
um just like if it comes up organically
I'm happy to talk about it but I don't
like wave the flag I don't lead with it
it's never my primary purpose I think
between us we have 30 years here right
15 10 5 5 yeah 30 yeah 5 10 15. you're
15 years cleaning yeah wow damn and it's
crazy huh that is nuts next thing you
know you're the same age as old people
yeah
that's the truth yeah it was the best
thing I could ever done oh dude he used
to live in a porta potty yeah
I live in a handicap sized porta potty
for two years while I was shooting dope
no kidding yeah
where was this Connecticut really yeah
and I was comfortable too I was chilling
yeah I was freezing in the winter
that's not Malibu yeah yeah
let's see how it goes man yeah see how
it goes and um it's it's really pretty
simple like you know if you decide to
dive into the whole thing we do we we
love welcoming people and and you know
it's like a herd you want to be in in
the herd yes right in the middle of the
herd yeah you know the Predators hate
the herd yeah they want they want to
wipe out the the injured sick ones that
wander up on their own yeah yeah so yeah
we stick together and we stay pretty
good yeah it's cool yeah man so uh so
everybody's gotta see buddy games Spring
Awakening buddy games Spring Awakening
it's a celebration of of spring break
lifestyle it's a celebration of uh maybe
growing old but not growing up yeah and
they find themselves in the situation
where it's kind of the Old Guard meets
the new guard you know they weren't
intending on going to spring break but
they kind of end up there in their suits
that they were in at the funeral
and decide that you know what and they
get pulled into this this
uh the games were stolen from this guy
that banned them from this club way back
in the day when they were there and they
it becomes this thing which then leads
them into this even darker place which
is uh extremely funny and uh we touched
on some some socially uh provocative
stuff which is yeah which is which but
in a really fun way good man and and and
that uh this will be out this Sunday off
right yes Friday it actually comes out
Friday the 19th of May okay well then
there there we go this would be Sunday
the 21st okay so okay as this some
people can see it now
yes they can they actually can get out
there and see it and then it goes on on
All Digital platforms I believe June 2nd
got it so but how it goes on digital
platforms is very influenced by how it
does in the theaters is that true yep
yeah
and then and and it is important to
support the movie in theaters for the
long-term success of it yeah and in all
respects yeah I agree and it's a really
fun movie to watch in the theater we
just did it the other night and it was
and people were curled over laughing so
it's a fun movie the cast Heavy Hitters
yeah Nick Swartz and Kevin Dillon yeah
great yeah so so to to support Josh
demell
and now we're on the other side if
there's anything that that you're not
comfortable with let's I'm pretty sure
Ashton Kutcher wouldn't mind no he's
gonna you know he's he's I've said I've
said it before
how about that that guy was a big time
movie star couldn't have been nicer
couldn't have been cooler couldn't have
been more open and vulnerable I mean man
I really think that was a special one
and he he did say that he has Instagram
right so what are you waiting for get on
over there and let him know how much he
impressed you how much he entertained
you how much you've warmed your heart
yeah dude get on it street team I'd love
for him to know how much you all enjoyed
that and I want you to know how much I
love you for sticking around to the end
Matt thank you
it's a win it's a win for me that you're
hearing me say this I really do love you
thanks bye-bye